Salut à tous ! Tous les jours une énigme. En tout cas tous les jours durant l'été, puisqu'on va s'arrêter à la fin du mois pour reprendre le rythme normal.
Avant de vous donner l'énigme du jour, je vous donne la solution l'énigme test psychologique d'hier.
J'espère que vous n'avez pas trouvé la réponse... Je vous expliquerez pourquoi...
Si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo d'hier regardez la avant d'écouter la réponse d'aujourd'hui.
Et bien elle a tué sa sœur parce qu'elle espérait que le garçon, comme ça, viendrait aux funérailles et qu'elle pourrait le revoir.
Il semblerait, c'est ce qu'il se dit, mais moi je n'ai trouvé aucune source confirmant ça, en tout cas sur je sujet
que c'est un test qu'on faisait pour détecter si quelqu'un était psychopathe ou pas.
Donc c'est une très très bonne nouvelle si vous n'avez pas trouvé la réponse. Il faut être un petit peu tord pour trouver la réponse.
Et si vous avez trouvé la réponse, moi je vous le dis, vous n'êtes pas tordu, vous êtes juste super intelligeant !
Même moi j'avais pas trouvé la réponse !
Du coup je suis content.
Et si vous le faites à des amis à vous et qu'ils trouvent la réponse... je vous conseille quand même d'être un peu prudent.
Allez ! On passe à l'énigme du jour ?!
Enigme 25, l'énigme d'un père et de son fils.
Un père et son fils ont a eux deux, 36 ans.
C'est-à-dire que si on additionne leur deux âges, ça nous fait 36.
Sachant que le père a 30 ans de plus que son fils,
quel âge a le fils ?
Ca parait simple comme ça donc prenez le temps d'y réfléchir un petit peu.
Ne mettez pas la réponse dans les commentaires.
Si vous avez trouvé mettez juste: "J'ai trouvé !" et mettez un pouce en l'air pour qu'on voit le nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la solution.
Solution que je vous donnerai comme d'habitude, dans la prochaine vidéo.
Profitez encore du soleil, des quelques derniers jours de vacances du mois d'août, si vous êtes en vacances.
Pensez bien sûr à vous abonner avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !